you know poker is about as American as
baseball and apple pie it was born here
in America Mark Twain loved it he's a
great American until recently Supreme
Court justices at a monthly game they're
great Americans so you'd think that
playing poker to VFW hall would be about
as American as anything he could do am i
right David Witherspoon and his wife
Stacy are regulars at veterans of
foreign wars post 1837 in Dallas they
had poker tournaments here I upon even
my wife played in with me all kinds of
people um and we had them from 21 to 81
you know we had families that were
coming play my whole family played here
we would just play cards ever you have
conversations we all go and have picnics
dinners David at Stacey look forward to
meeting friends like Brenda wigington
and Vietnam vet Wayne Logan I was
operation specialist US navy stuff a
long time ago I mold down Brendan Wayne
organized the VFW poker tournaments
members have fun playing cards and the
events raise money which the VFW uses to
pay rent electricity bills and donate to
all kinds of charities can trade
research fun food basket for the
veterans overseas and also the homeless
and police chi minh charities as well
because we had police officers at played
here as well one day tragedy hit David's
family he turned to the VFW for help my
son died a year ago with the drug that
called cheese which is a new drug out
all the kids in school you know they can
get high for two dollars but it's
actually heroin you know they just got a
name for it called cheese and so they
actually did a tournament here for him
go we were trying to start an
organization we had a live band that day
there's a lot of fun with all the
families that did come and their
children during
today we had food we had prizes for them
to when people donated gifts that day
the VFW raised about four thousand
dollars for a charity created a memory
of David's son that helps families
struggling with drug abuse it was just a
big nice of it folks continue to gather
at the VFW post until one night during a
poker tournament when everything changed
my wife had actually just got now the
tournament she was over there with me
and we were sitting there just playing
pool and I mean here they come through
the door with masks and you know what
you and guns and everything we're going
he'll look in the world is going on here
the Dallas Police Department's vice
squad rated VFW Post 1837 for running an
illegal gambling room oh they told
everybody is in in the VFW and around
the pool table was the bar and
everything to not move I don't care what
position you were in like they had me
put my hands up against the bar and I
was not to move for about an iron 45
minutes say it took approximately 10
table they took out i think sixty eight
hundred dollars in cash they took our
flat screen TVs our poker chips anything
was related to poker you know here they
are coming in here and Reaganism we help
them so one lady that was crying peed on
her say how such as it got the best can
i go the bathroom and wouldn't let her
go to the bathroom the police charged
dozens of VFW members with misdemeanor
offenses and the punishment range is up
to six months in the county jail and a
fine of up to a thousand dollars the
card playing if the VFW did violate
Texas law it's not illegal to have a
card game and have people wager with
each other as card players it's only
illegal if the house gets a cut it's
illegal even though the VFW used the
money to help charities and pay the rent
police ultimately said that the reason
they were alerted to this is because of
some neighbor who thought that gambling
was very dangerous for society as I say
gambling's illegal us a lot of the the
law prohibits the citizens of the state
of Texas from gambling but does not
prohibit the state of Texas from
gambling and taking a percentage of the
cut Dallas PD vice squad did not respond
our interview requests the priority of
going after veterans of foreign wars
playing cards on Friday night rather
than to try to get to the root of the
crime we've got here is is pretty sad we
were not able to operate and pay our
bills because we had no place for the
players to play months after the raid
VFW Post 1837 stands empty now they've
shut this place down this was a place
for veterans to come this was not just a
poker room well I don't know what to do
now we have no VFW for reason TV I'm
drew Carey